luke lee panthers linebacker ninth
overall pick in the 2012 draft what a
crazy top ten that is go back and look
at that top ten ryan tannehill number
eight that year is starting a conference
championship game kieckley's retired
andrew luck the first overall pick is
retired rg3 the second overall pick is a
backup quarterback trent richardson long
gone just amazing wow what's become of
that group in fewer than eight years but
luke keegley deciding to walk away that
was the stunner last night and that
inspires
our draft for today chris the best
middle linebackers or inside linebackers
in a 3-4 of all time no trivia question
today i'm just going to give you the
first pick since i feel bad that you
were sick yesterday thank you so much
i'm just giving you the first pick yes i
know you are um all right well i mean
that's it's an easy first pick i mean
i'm going with ray lewis
ray lewis is certainly the best middle
linebacker of our generation and you
know again was i alive to watch other
great linebackers you know in the 60s
and 70s no but i've watched a whole lot
of nfl films anybody that knows me and
grew up around me or anything knows i
was obsessed with that but ray lewis is
the best middle linebacker i ever saw
for sure i mean one of the best leaders
we've ever seen playmaking ability early
in his career was great in the past game
won a super bowl mvp all the old parole
all pros all the pro bowls i mean
baltimore is who they are right now to
this day
because of what ray lewis created there
the attitude around the baltimore ravens
he's kind of transcended that way that's
why i think he's an easy number one pick
here
yeah i i agree with you that that's the
first guy off the board although i would
say that maybe later in his career
yeah that was a little smoking mirrors
sure he played a long long time and the
leadership the intensity and you had to
deal with it i mean you've told the
story before about that ravens defense
when you were playing and and having
those guys up up coming after you
breathing fire uh as you try to figure
out how to how to solve that that
defense and ray lewis leading the way
i'm i'm staying in that same general
vicinity of the world but this was long
before the ravens were the ravens they
were the browns when this guy was
patrolling the middle of defenses when i
think middle linebacker the first guy i
think of is jack lambert because he was
for a guy who was not very big maybe 225
and he had the the shoulder pads that
were extra big that made him actually
look even smaller the guy was fierce the
guy was vicious the guy was intimidating
one of my favorite moments one of my
most most enduring memories of watching
the super bowl as a kid was when super
bowl 10 roy jarrella misses the field
goal cliff harris of the cowboys goes
over and kind of pats him on the head
and jack lambert notices it goes over
grabs chris harris by the jersey and
throws him to the ground that was jack
lambert
all the time and when he retired he just
like disappeared and he rarely does
anything now yeah rarely ever hear from
is like a park ranger somewhere in the
middle of pennsylvania that guy to me
when i thought football player not just
middle linebacker when i thought
football player in the 70s jack lambert
was the first guy i thought yeah well i
get it i mean he he looks football
player i mean just mean nasty got that
neck collar on he's missing teeth
you know you hear all the stories about
him you know behind the scenes i know
tony dungy's told us a few good stories
and he was working with the steelers in
those days
i mean yeah he's tough he just
epitomizes you know steel curtain middle
linebacker tough man football so i'm
with you there he was certainly a name i
had here towards the top of my list uh
let me tell you one let me share one
quick story that tony shared with us
that can be repeated not that there's a
bunch of bad stories about jack lambert
but tony said the first time they played
in cleveland when he was on the steelers
jack lambert told him before the game
whatever you do do not take off your
helmet those fans are crazy they will
throw anything at you keep your helmet
on at all times so during the game jack
lambert blows a gasket takes his helmet
off is swinging it around and yelling
and screaming gets ejected and as he's
leaving the field tony says to jack
lambert hey you said never to take your
helmet off
and jack lambert was mad at him for that
comment but just very dry very sly hey
jack you said never take your helmet off
so uh
who do you got next uh all right i'm
gonna go with junior seau i mean junior
say how other than ray lewis for for my
generation is the next guy up as far as
great middle linebackers i mean growing
up watching junior seyou whether it was
at usc uh the san diego chargers or the
new england patriots i mean special i
mean just an intensity about the way he
played but you know i think it was the
you know hey the ability to blitz the
ability to run sideline to sideline you
know the emotion and intensity in which
he played with also you know you hear
all the stories with junior say how to
not always doing what he was coached to
do had a little bit of like you know
lawrence taylor back in the 80s and what
he used to do just sometimes he just did
whatever the hell he wanted and you went
oh no don't do that oh good play junior
good play i mean you hear those stories
all the time hey junior what'd you see
there to blitz i don't know i just saw
the gap and i decided to fly through it
okay hey good thing it worked out i mean
junior seahai to me uh again just like
fearsome crazy middle linebacker always
was flying high yup i mean had that
awesome celebration uh for me he's
certainly one of the guys i think of
when i think middle linebacker
and you know at a time when we are
speculating that head injuries may have
had something to do with luke keakley's
decision to retire at the age of 28.
junior sale played 20 years insane four
before the nfl had its concussion
epiphany think of how many head injuries
he had and of course we know the story
about the suicide and the the cte and
and the litigation and uh you know it's
it's been a tragic story on the back end
but all those years of playing
high-impact high-level violent football
before the nfl
realized we need to be more diligent
about diagnosing concussions keeping
guys out until they're healed how many
times did
junior sale get his bell rung yeah it
may have been every time he made a
tackle so uh he was a special special
player and uh good pick by you for round
two i you know i i think of middle
linebacker position generally and i
think chicago bears because they've had
so many right from brian urlacher back
to mike singletary to dick butkus only
one of the three made the all-time team
though and that was dick butkus so
that's my next pick and what just what
what what a football name right jack
lambert dick
the football player you think of when
you see him but dick butkus just screams
out i play football like you don't have
to at when you meet dick butkus you
don't have to ask him what do you do for
a living you know what he does for a
living he's a football player you're
right yeah he's not like oh i'm uh i run
a floral shop around the corner my
name's dick butkus nice to meet you what
you do no you don't sound like that
you're right i mean he's the way he
looks everything about him tough chicago
bears i mean you're right there i don't
know if there is a name that moore says
middle linebacker than
dick buck is i mean certainly uh he is
he is like the iconic figure i think
there and i feel bad because you know
i'm gonna pick a more of a new age guy
again uh maybe it's better you go the
old school guys because you're old and
i'm new so that's probably better that
way uh but i'm gonna go with a teammate
that i played with i got to go with
derek brooks here all right uh i'm gonna
go with derek brooks one because i think
he's you know one of the first of his
kind as far as this new age nfl
linebacker where we see that's more
predicated on athleticism right derek
brooks wasn't necessarily like ray lewis
or dick buckus where it was just like oh
yeah i'm gonna smash you in the hole and
you're you know i'm gonna drive back the
guard and the the running back and the
four-yard loss no
derek brooks was yes he could do that
stuff but the name of his game was
athleticism and smarts and he was
certainly one of the smartest players i
ever played against he was a pain in
butt in practice he'd call out plays all
the time but man in his prime derrick
brooks could run with tight ends and
running backs up the seam of course you
see the pick six he had in the super
bowl and all that he was phenomenal in
the past game and it was the tampa two
scheme was successful because of a guy
like him where yeah the middle
linebacker's gone and he had enough
speed underneath to
close all those holes and and all those
holes within the zone let alone two
safeties are back i'm athletic enough to
cover a lot of holes in the run game too
all the time too uh derek brooks is
pretty special
you're taking a little bit of a liberty
there you're taking a little a little
bit well a little bit he's like covered
at the end by sliding him inside in the
nickel package he's not really a middle
linebacker but he's a four suit so what
i think of middle linebacker too is 4-3
like anybody within the 4-3 scheme there
to me is middle
linebacker-ish right so that's where i
kind of went with it i guess you're
right he's probably designated as a real
linebacker in the 4-3 scheme but
nonetheless was between the tackles mike
so you're right i probably gave myself a
little liberty but deal with it
and and also possibly junior sale but
that's okay all right for me and and
look uh he made the all-time team
and i just remember back in my formative
years my impressionable years watching
football
the any time i saw willie lanier on a
football field i paid attention yeah
right and and i don't know whether it
was that that extra little strip he had
on his helmet you know he had that extra
little bump that piece that you know for
extra head protection but 63 of the
kansas city chiefs i i said 63 chiefs
willie lanier that's always the guy it's
willie lanier and that's kind of like
the first middle linebacker i became
aware of when i started watching
football so you know you could make
arguments for other guys and i know mike
singletary's being left off this list
and erlacker and some others but to me
and i'm just thinking of guys and i've
picked guys from years ago but that
middle linebacker position it felt like
it was more important back in the 60s
and 70s and those were the guys butkus
lanier lambert so third rounder for me
is willie lanier yeah i mean uh you know
again when i was growing up and watching
all i mean he certainly was you know
iconic for that chief team wearing 63
to me too looked like you know a guy
that was a little ahead of his time as
far as athleticism at that position too
you know he instead of like the dick
buckets it was purely run stuff for all
that lanier looked like he could really
run sideline to skyline hey apologies to
chuck benarek ray nisky those guys they
deserve to be in this conversation too
they certainly were there for me i just
wasn't alive to see them so i picked
guys that i was alive to see more more
or less
and chuck ben eric the last of the two
weight players played center and inside
linebacker for the philadelphia eagles
from 1949 to 1962. harry potter
as well yeah yeah yeah uh yeah plenty of
great great linebackers outside and
inside but luke lee you know where is he
uh how many rounds we have to go before
we get to keekley would it be round
round four round five round six where do
you think he would have landed that's a
real good question i would say yes
probably towards around that round five
to six range i guess uh
have to think about that but regardless
he's going to the hall of fame i know
that and that's that's all that needs to
be said he was a special player
who was really awesome and impactful for
some really good defenses and a team
that was you know in the super bowl
because of his play and what he could do
at the linebacker position
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports